Ellos le llevarán al hospital en su propio auto, mientras se está muriendo
y permanecerán en la sala de espera mientras los médicos le ponen un bypass.
Ellos no querrán que se sienta solo, traerán libros para leer.
Y dejarán que se aloje en su casa noches extra sin cobrar.
¡Muy recomendable!"
(Aplausos)
Por supuesto, no todas las estancias son así.
Pero esta conexión, más allá de la transacción
es exactamente a lo que apunta la economía del compartir.
Cuando oí ese término,
debo admitir, que me confundió.
¿Cómo compartir y hacer transacciones pueden ir de la mano?
Así que seamos claros; se trata de comercio.
Pero si lo llamamos solo economía de alquiler,
sería incompleto.
La economía del compartir es el comercio con la promesa de la conexión humana.
Las personas comparten una parte de sí mismos,
y eso lo cambia todo.
Como hoy la mayor parte de los viajes son como
la comida rápida...
es eficiente y consistente,
a costa de lo local y lo auténtico.
¿Qué pasaría si los viajes fueran como un magnífico buffet
de experiencias locales?
¿Qué pasaría si en cualquier lugar que ha visitado,
hubiera un mercado central de locales
ofreciendo lograr que uno se emborrache
en visitas a bares en los barrios que ni siquiera sabía que existían.
O aprender a cocinar con el chef de un restaurante de cinco estrellas.
Hoy las casas están diseñadas en torno a la idea de la privacidad y la separación.
¿Qué pasa si los hogares fueran diseñados para compartirse a partir de cero?
¿Cómo se vería eso?
¿Qué pasa si las ciudades adoptan una cultura de intercambio?
Veo un futuro en ciudades compartidas que nos traen comunidad y conexión
en lugar de aislamiento y separación.
En Corea del Sur, en Seúl,
en realidad han comenzado.
Han reutilizado cientos de plazas de aparcamiento del gobierno
para compartir con los residentes.
Están conectados a estudiantes que necesitan un lugar para vivir,
nidos vacíos que tienen habitaciones adicionales.
Y han empezado una incubadora para ayudar a financiar la próxima generación
de empresas de economía compartida de nueva creación.
Esta noche solo en nuestro servicio,
785 000 personas
en 191 países
o bien estarán en la casa de un extraño
o darán la bienvenida a uno en la suya.
Claramente, no es tan loco como nos han enseñado.
No hemos inventado nada nuevo.
La hospitalidad ha existido siempre.
Ha habido muchos otros sitios web como el nuestro.
Así que, ¿por qué la nuestra finalmente despega?
Con suerte y el tiempo a nuestro lado,
he aprendido que se puede tomar los componentes de la confianza,
y se puede diseñar para eso.
El diseño puede superar nuestros prejuicios más arraigados
de extraño es igual a peligro.
Y eso es increíble para mí.
Es cautivante.
Pienso en esto cada vez que veo un Miata rojo pasar.
Sabemos que el diseño no resolverá todos los problemas del mundo.
Pero si puede ayudar,
si se puede hacer mella en esto,
eso me hace pensar, ¿qué más podemos diseñar para el futuro?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)